I hate inaccurate information to my
videos it haunts me seriously you know
what I hate more than inaccurate
information to my videos nothing there's
nothing I hate more alright so in my
trailer review for Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain I said that there are
some continuity issues because the lays
infanterie project happened in 1972 and
it happened when he was in a coma but
now he's in a coma in this game so I was
like oh there's a little bit of
confliction there and in the comments
section a couple of people were like
well what if this is a different coma
and I was like that means he's pretty
prone to comas how many comas does this
guy have to go through however in doing
further research it looks like this is a
totally different color we're gonna
rewind a piece Walker and this has a
couple of spoilers for Peace Walker if
you haven't played Peace Walker in peace
Walker it starts out he has left the
United States he's kind of like he's a
nomad you know big boss is like I'm on
my own but I never really knew why I was
like is that because of the Suns a big
boss because you know that he had a
falling-out with zero when the Suns a
big boss were created but someone in the
comments section of my video I did on
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain was
like out on Peace Walker there's this
recording you can hear of a phone call
between Kaz Miller and zero and they're
talking they talk about the sun's a big
box I was like what
so why YouTube this and this exists it's
Cass Miller going yeah how are the kids
all there's two of them that's cool why
I wonder how big boss is gonna react
when he finds out about this and I was
like how did I miss arguably node
actually the most important dialogue in
the entire peace walker game but thirty
five hours into that game never heard
that and I explained it like this we are
on earth planet Earth is a rock in the
middle of the solar system in the middle
of a galaxy in the middle of space that
has found the power to sustain life it's
a miracle
so stranger things have happened in the
universe and me missing the most
important piece of dialogue and peace
Walker not by much but earth sustaining
life is slightly more extraordinary I
don't know how I miss that seriously and
so I rectify the situation I correct
myself I don't usually do videos
correcting myself I was really careful
in this video to okay oh there's someone
with a gas mask but we don't know what
Psycho Mantis alright so I called mother
base outer heaven but it is outer heaven
because he does reference it as outer
heaven is like oh it's more of an outer
heaven so outer heaven is a frame of
mind it's an ideology of big boss in
that mother base is still outer heaven
so it's fine actually it's fine but I
was like but I'm gonna really talk about
this continuity issues that I now know
don't exist
big boss just goes into his second coma
in this game however I
I'm wondering if Metal Gear Solid 5 does
play into the creation of solidus snake
make sure wonder who that dude in the
mask is the guy in the mask and the
phantom pain trailer he's voiced by Jack
Bauer e's voiced by Kiefer Sutherland
which is funny because when I was
watching 24 I always called Jack Bauer
solid a snake I'm not saying that is
solid a snake he's just funny that I
called Kiefer Sutherland in 24 solidus
snake and now Kiefer Sutherland is a
voice in Metal Gear Solid it's a funny
world not like anything really weird and
stupid happened like me missing the most
important piece of dialogue and peace
Walker that does led to me giving false
information in a video um people have
asked me if I'm gonna play and review
Metal Gear Rising revisited since miss
or whatever it is Metal Gear Rising no
I'm not gonna play that game why because
Ryden got his resolution at the end of
Metal Gear Solid 4 Metal Gear Rising
takes place after Metal Gear Solid 4 so
he has to gear up and go out there and
do more work I hate that I don't like
the fact that that game negates the
resolution that Ryden got at the end of
4 you know when people are like oh
that's dumb and stupid I hate it and
then your logical response is well if
you don't want to play it then don't
play I'm going to exercise that logic
and not play the game because I don't
want to so there that is so good news is
the sons of BigBoss have already been
created two years before peace walker no
Metal Gear Solid 5 takes place the sons
a big boss would be like 10 years old at
this point that's kind of cool I don't
know what we're gonna see I do know that
that sucks asked at all this time ever
since I played peace walker I've been
like that doesn't actually fit because I
missed one piece of dialogue all the
while it actually did fit in any case
that is me giving you updated
information on something I just learned
that I should have learned a while ago
but just learn now I hope that fixes
things here and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]